what did you think because you're a
model so I'm just asking like what did
you think very very good yes creative
it's so creative it's sort of it's not
easy especially now kind of in the days
of instagramming and things like that I
enlist my husband to do it a lot of the
times but I had a background in modeling
actually before I started yeah acting
III modeled I was actually in Japan I
was doing a an ad for Sony of all of all
things and I had a monkey that was I was
working with that day his name is dodo
Chon we'll never forget that name I
promise and he was really really sweet
running all over the place and kind of
posing with me and on me and then we had
a lunch break and then donut cons like a
spider monkey exactly a little spider
monkey don't be fooled by how cute they
are
yeah but there was my girl big bowls of
fruit and everybody watched his dotage
on just like saw that bull of fruit and
just did like just dove into the
passionfruit and the Kiwi and all of
them were like oh my god he loves the
fruit it's so great they were like
alright everybody back to work and Jota
John decided he wanted to like pose on
top of my head and we thought that was
super cute I know where this is
until and you see there where this is
going dodo just completely relieved
himself
please tell me that photo is somewhere I
let me tell you what I'd gone back to
Japan the following year and there on
the subway were the ads of me and I
remember looking at it because it was
such a horrific day but you wouldn't
tell like I looked so happy was like
sitting on my shoulder and I was like
this and we've gotten really close so we
got really bad so yeah it's a different
level of relationship I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this